sébastien vallier la négociation donc ma
part admis rockets et ce week-end
papa radier qui ça al pacino
oh merde c'est mon téléphone pardon
ollada les écueils c'est mon banquier
répond pas maintenant en revanche j'ai
reçu un texto à l'instant tout à l'heure
on me disait que johnny hallyday le
disque de johnny hallyday sadc le record
de tous les temps en france des disques
vendus donc on en parlera donc c'est
vrai paparazzi al pacino il faut pas le
dire mais pas que vous vous êtes
introduit dans les coulisses du théâtre
poil avant c'est vrai mais non bah il y
avait une exclusivité il fallait pas
faire de photos donc voilà donc vous
avez fait il faut pas ils étaient deux
jours au théâtre al pacino cet acteur
les places et les jusqu'à 950 euros je
crois à fait et voilà du coup voilà il
ya il y avait des vigiles postés dans
tous les coins de la salle ils ont
prévenu le premier qui fait une photo on
le sort tout de suite et c'est donc
grosse exclusivité de quelqu'un à mon
avis est ce qui est marrant quand il n
exclut ces deux cas celles exclues